yeah i'm the greatest mma journalist of
all time ever yeah
break that down
i don't get it it's pretty [ __ ]
obvious i don't get what happened
what is there to break down not breaking
there's nothing
and there's journalism and then when
they cross it's shultz that's all you
see there's no one else there's ariel
helwani i'm ready to do a face-off with
him right now yeah just watching your
[ __ ] nose mash into each other from a
mile away
from the other side of the podium
and touching noses that's great no but
for real i'm the greatest mma journalist
of all time a lot of people know this
about me uh those who don't um [ __ ] your
mother sucks so you're my dick
that's true like if you didn't know that
about me your mother sucks my dick maybe
that's another thing you didn't notice
but maybe you did notice that also you
know just walking around wheezing all
the time that's me clearing out space in
her throat jesus
it's true
they're things that are true they're
they're things that are factual okay
yeah yeah did genghis khan have the
greatest empire in history was he the
greatest conqueror
okay yeah uh was it really tough getting
rynas arrived from south sudan toronto
okay um
am i the greatest mma journalist of all
time yeah yes do i know all things mma
but what qualifies you like what's your
authority oh you know this right here
that's my number one qualifier right
there that is that is my number one so
happy they weren't respecting your
greatness okay so i was i'm watching an
mma fight all right okay as i do which
would you receive it say again would you
have seen that oh some people were
fighting and uh
i forgot it was fine but it was some
people that was doing the whole fighting
and yeah
yeah with the little mittens they got
the little cut out there big j okay it
was like
they got the big day hookers and gloves
in there and they're like hugging and
wrestling what is that you wrote a
motorcycle here
i paid for the pay-per-view i'm like i'm
watching it it was
so i'm watching skankfest and then
there's a girl that comes on there's two
girls that come on to fight right
what i know and i've been telling all
these people this on the internet they
come for the ring like every time the
ring is the round is
i see the girls in the ring and i'm like
okay they're here to clean up some of
the blood off of the ground or something
like that they're getting the fight
ready for the necessary thing because
here's the thing i'm a fan of female mma
and i've said this before but only if
they were born with penises that's the
only female mma stars
that's progressive son i'm the most
progressive guy that you can imagine i'm
the i'm the foremost historian on
progress
listen i am the greatest journalist when
it comes to progress okay yeah i put
myself in the line of fire
wow i've done this before many times
yeah what name one time where i wasn't
alive infamous
i was there when the taliban took it
over in afghanistan i was in you guys
no i do not remember me being late for
the podcast i was like i'll be right
there i was just saying i'm gonna say
that
in texas say again i think we're in
dallas i've been in texas i've been in
every place yeah okay that's the thing
i've been literally everywhere like a
lot of you guys listen and i'm not
trying to be disrespectful to you guys
but you don't understand it's like to
take ronastros from south sudan to rome
because you haven't been to south sudan
right if you've been like me i've been
there dude i plucked a mean out of the
sudan
and placed him at [ __ ] espn how do
you think he got here
same way we got the rhinoceros
you're a hero you're a hero i'm a hero
you're a hero i find talent i remember
and sweden and sweden they're racially
profiling me you stepped in front and i
tried to racially profile me yeah you
know what i mean yeah and then he
charged me like that when i started i
know better i had experience i have
experience
i gave him the little fingers i gave him
jazz hands bro i gave him jazz hands
first of all no black people sweet there
are no jazzes if they did
if they did that probably would have
worked he would have respected it he
would have respected it
so [ __ ] him [ __ ] sweden [ __ ] i'm
one of the most uh renowned historians
of sweden too
i am i literally am i still want to know
what happened yeah so a few so a few
people have brought forward your tweets
and said that you were inaccurate or uh
just outright disrespectful i'm watching
this [ __ ] cleaning lady disrespectful
it's so funny some people are suggesting
okay i was disrespectful to one of them
when i said that she looked like a diner
waitress that was disrespectful but i
was charged up that was funny i was also
hilarious yeah i also undeniably funny
line for fans of a sport where people re
like literally will kill each other
sometimes yeah you're kind of cucks oh
no no no that was so offensive
too we're gonna get you sound like
aoc fans not ufc fans no yeah these
these are definitely like there's a q a
on portion of the the ufc family yes
like especially with mma like he's
digging a crate
listen
if you come at the king you best not
miss i'm the greatest journalist in ufc
he might not miss okay that's the point
you cannot miss
hey this is honestly their fault say
what because you tried to have a fight
party and then these guys all act like
they were too busy they could have
stopped you from tweeting that [ __ ]
if you were here with other people that
could have been like yo yo you're baby
tiger in it again oh i regret it oh you
think you would have said it out loud
and then god
i regret it
i was on mushrooms in the desert and
oh because i didn't have [ __ ] at the
party that's the thing right
[Music]
real men at the party understood how to
talk [ __ ] and they would charge me up
and i was just talking my feelings bro
that's what it is if i have feelings i
speak them the girl that was fighting
this girl chef chanko right she's
supposed to be the have you ever watched
a chef tango fight no no have you ever
watched a ship tango fight come on
exactly have you ever watched the chip
channel fight maybe but i don't remember
exactly you don't remember that you know
five-time fighter champion you know that
because of the comments on my [ __ ]
paws the point is i i what i said to her
i'm seeing this if we're being real
about if we're actually not being
hyperbolic here or not being sarcastic
we're actually going to be real this
girl is incredibly skilled yeah
like amazing striker and i'm watching
i've never seen her fight before i've
heard her name a little bit i i
understand all these mma fans they
[ __ ] love the the female mma [ __ ]
like that i don't know what it is that's
weird to me i think it's there's a whole
thing where it's like i get to lust over
a woman but it looks like i care about
support yeah you know what i mean
like a main card there have been main
cards where you didn't expect to enjoy a
female fight and it was the best fight
of the night yes or no there's been some
incredible things
like watching female mma
so so so what i'm doing is
listen it was unnecessary it was
unnecessary listen everybody getting
these shots
listen when you come for the greatest
mma journalist in history i have to back
up what i'm talking about okay obviously
so i tweet things out and naturally
since i'm the greatest mma journalist in
history they're gonna react right i'm
not just some pundit i'm not just some
guy with a podcast who like maybe just
started watching mma a couple years ago
and i find it interesting and i'm a big
fan of the sport right and i try to do
my best to promote the fighters so that
they can make [ __ ] money and use our
platform so they can do i'm not that i'm
the greatest mma journalist in history
right that's who i am so i understand
whatever i say you know this is high
stakes here okay so this chevchenko girl
she's in the ring okay
the [ __ ] ring the octagon whatever
you want to call it okay it doesn't
matter what do you call it as a
journalist what do i call it yeah i i
thought it was a broom closet when i saw
those two girls in there i thought it
was a broom closet right i did think
that right so i see the girls in there
this chef chango girl in all seriousness
is incredibly skilled and the other girl
i'm sure she's [ __ ] a beast
but she's not as skilled
i know enough fight sports to know i
know enough about fight sports that to
know when one is at a completely
different level okay
here's the thing
shivchenko carries her for four rounds
gets the finish in the fourth round i
tweeted earlier thing i'm like what do
you do like when you're there's this
much of a skill discrepancy you need to
get this chick or dude out of here early
the thing about the ufc which is amazing
is they just reward entertainment if you
take risks and get knocked out you'll be
fighting three in three months again if
it's entertaining it doesn't matter the
final card i don't know if you guys saw
it you guys didn't see it but the final
card was one of the most amazing cards
i've ever seen neither fighter lost any
ground in terms of promotion brian
ortega for volkanowski neither fight
both of them can fight again there's
even more interest bokonowski won
amazing [ __ ] heart but so did ortega
it was amazing the fight i'm watching
this girl carry this other girl from
four rounds i'm just like
what the [ __ ] are you wasting our time
for okay you are so much better than
this girl she's not willing to take the
risk in order to be a superstar amanda
nunes the only reason i know her name is
because she goes in the ring and she
leaves women unconscious
okay you know who amanda nunes is yes
you know who amanda nunes is you know
maybe you don't know who amanda nunes is
you know a man who she goes in the ring
and leaves women unconscious yeah okay
that's the only way ronda rousey
yeah she was a [ __ ] wwe star goes in
the ring leaves girls unconscious or
taps in the [ __ ] out or chokes them out
whatever judo [ __ ] she was doing so she
ran into holly holm and then it was over
point is the only way that people are
gonna know you especially if you're a
female in the fight sports is if you're
finishing people ain't nobody got time
for the technique people talking about
oh she speaks seven languages
bravo go work for the fbi
get a job at the cia
you know what man this is amazing if you
want to make the millions and millions
and millions of dollars if you want to
have a [ __ ] wwe contract when you're
done
if you want to be a global superstar
it's [ __ ] knockouts and dominance and
carrying a girlfriend that nobody
[ __ ] knows about for four rounds
right and i have all the respect in
world people actually go in the ring but
careful it's not how you do it the fact
that none of us know who she is i know
these mma fans that's their whole life
so they think that everybody knows who
they are it's not it's just like comics
we think comedies our whole lives so
when you don't know a comic we're like
how the [ __ ] do you not know
how do you not know who that is we can't
fathom it because we're so insulated in
our circle but the casuals the casuals
are where you make the real money the
casual is where you change your [ __ ]
life change your family's life forever
they want to see carnage bro it's the
easiest thing to digest
so i made this observation i was like
this girl's so talented she's choosing
to not take the risk necessary to get
this girl out in a round
and be a [ __ ]
[Applause]
superstar you